[Music]
Thanksgiving has ended and here's how
some of our favorite celebs celebrated
Kylie Jenner hosted an extravagant
Thanksgiving dinner with her family Tyga
Kendall Kris and Caitlyn were all
present but noticeably absent from any
Kardashian family photos Kanye West who
remains in the hospital due to
exhaustion Taylor Swift spent the day
frozen on the beach with friends and
family
and by that we mean she was nailing the
mannequin challenge before breaking it
down meanwhile BFF Selena Gomez is
resurfacing on social media she posted a
photo with her fans captioning it my
year has been the hardest yet most
rewarding one yet I finally fought the
fight of not being enough I have only
wanted to reflect the love you guys have
given me for years and show how
important it is to take care of you Katy
Perry and Orlando Bloom shutdown break
up rumors looking cozy in PJs as they
get ready to eat turkey another celeb
couple going strong Blake Shelton and
Gwen Stefani who shared a sweet smooch
skier Lindsey Vaughn is on the men from
her fractured arm but is still feeling
thankful posting this collage of friends
family and her boyfriend at Kenan Smith
another athlete feeling thankful LA Rams
Roger saffle who spent his Thanksgiving
volunteering he and his family handed
out meals to packs homeless and formerly
homeless clients at pink taco in Los
Angeles
you